[Musik]
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 es
sieht sehr sehr sehr sehr geil aus hier
gerade mit dem sonnenlicht das hier
vorne unsere kleine süße lichtung
scheint und ich kann mir das wirklich in
zukunft der forschung wenn man
dahingegen den weizenfeld noch ist und
hier eine kuh farben oder irgendwie
keine ahnung was und dann sind überall
so die wollen wir so ein bisschen
gefällt überall scheint die sonne hin
alles ist verbunden mit wegen das ist
uns heute allerdings wirklich
schnurzpiepegal erstmal denn bereits im
titel eingeblendeten der ein oder andere
wird auch schon wissen um was es hier
heute geht eventuell wenn man meinen
zweikanal kennt weiß man direkt was
heute abgeht und zwar zuallererst mal
info dass das heutige video
ungeschnitten sein wird also ich werde
natürlich selbstverständlich das höre
ich auch bereits im hintergrund die
sachen einen blenden wie
hintergrundmusik oder townes von
beispielsweise wenn wir verschiedene
monster entdecken oder irgendwie sowas
in der richtung das würde ich dann wäre
ich natürlich schon ein wenden
allerdings werde ich auf schritte
verzichten so dass ihr wirklich ganz
genau sieht was ich wie wann wo pipapo
mache also ich werde hier nicht
überspringen ich werde hier nicht
irgendwie einen machen aufbau jetzt time
labs oder irgendwie so dass wir uns erst
recht heute geben weil das wird den sinn
des videos ein bisschen kaputt machen
sondern ich werde mich wirklich darauf
konzentrieren
dass ich versuche euch zu unterhalten
ohne dass sich eben etwas wegschneiden
und das video thema wird sein dass ich
einen diamanten finden muss jan oder
andere wie bereits gesagt er sich mit
meinem zweiten kanal auskennen und
abonnent von luxo kanal ist der weiß
dass ich dort eine sehr erfolgreiche sie
sehr erfolgreiche serie habe wo ich
beispielsweise freunde von mir also
sandra oder irgendwelche anderen leute
oder auch teilweise mich selber
challenges vorsätze und
nur wenn ich dann beispielsweise dieses
wort sagen oder diese sache mache oder
wenn dies und das passiert endet das
video deswegen oder seht ihr ja auch
bereits den titel eingeblendet endet das
video heute direkt wenn ich einen
diamanten finde es wird nicht so sein
dass ich in diamanten sehr und dann baue
ich den ab und dann wird es halt so sein
wie jetzt habe ich diamanten und jetzt
gehen wir nach oben ich sehe einen
diamanten und dann ist das video vorbei
es kann sein dass das jetzt nach einer
minute passiert weshalb ich mir gedacht
habe dass ich über lieber jetzt direkt
zu beginn hier sage leute wenn euch das
video bzw diese idee sage ich mal jetzt
schon mal gefällt dann lasst gern einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr bock habt auf weitere
solcher kreativen ideen man kann das
auch mit anderen sachen machen in
minecraft und
[Musik]
das kann ich noch nicht sagen deswegen
dass mir dass ich jetzt lieber sagen und
ich werde das ganze hier auch schon seht
ihr ja so ein bisschen aufbauen dass ich
mich hier nicht verlaufen also ich würd
alle türen ausbauen und überall muss
schlussendlich nicht so wirklich lang
geht weiß ich dann da wir laufen ist
natürlich die musik wir müssen wir
bis sich ein stimmung reinbringen
ich glaube es bringt nichts
[Musik]
das ich jetzt irgendwie links oder
rechts die fackeln setzte in diesem
stronghold sondern da muss ich will
man muss sich wirklich damit arbeiten
dass sich die orte an denen ich schon
war wirklich einfach zu
faul hier vorne
was ist denn das was ist denn das
was ist denn das für eine riesenspinne
[Musik]
die kommt aber nicht
oh mein gott
so kam ich bekam ich habe mich erholt
wir wollen auf den zug
wie baue ich will nicht ich werde ich
schreibe es in die kommentare was das
war
hey ich hab ich kriege herzrasen von
sowas nenne ich habe so angst vor
spinnen er jetzt weiß ich einfach dass
es davon hier solche teile gibt
kein diamant okay das video endet an der
stelle hier noch nicht allerdings geht
es hier weiter ich hab es los geht es
hier noch lang meistens ist es ja so
dass wenn die gänge hier plötzlich
anders dann weitergeht hier allerdings
nicht
hey ich hasse so was ich hasse solche
spiel minecraft alter bitte nie wieder
hier geht's auch neben solang ich will
das auch nicht aufbauen bitte bitte
schreibt mir die kommentare ob dagegen
stark ist was das machen kann mit mir
ich habe
bitte schreibt mir die kommentare
was das für eine ekelhafte spinne war
geht's hier lang
ok jetzt weiter
[Musik]
hätte schießen sich darum gegenseitig ab
ich kann einfach nicht schneiden heute
so was kann ich das nicht in der time
netz lösen ihr seht heute alles
steht dann noch wenn ich glaub nicht
perfekte
ganz ruhig
[Musik]
ich habe es so schiss vor spinnen ihr
ahnt es nicht ich hab so schiss vor
diesem ding dass wir das irgendwann mal
wieder sehen ich weiß nicht ob das hier
der gang war aber ich glaube jetzt
einfach mal weiter hier vorne geht es
glaube ich nicht lang
hier ist alles easy ich glaube jetzt mal
hier runter mal schauen ob es hier
irgendwo lang geht hier geht's auf jeden
fall
[Musik]
das sind normale spinner
ich gehe raus ich gehe raus
leute ich hasse sowas wirklich ich denke
mir das nicht aus mein herz rast ich
zitter ich habe angst vor spinnen ich
hasse so was und
ich
weiß nicht ob das daher kommt dass wir
hier immer weiter runter gehen
oder ob hier noch mehr von solchen
teilen kommen
habe ich hab'
ich habe richtig richtig schiss vor so
was
es geht weiter runter
es geht weiter runter wir haben erneute
kiste zwei eisen und eisen schert
keine diamanten keine diamanten bisher
einfach weitergehen luca
[Musik]
scheint so als wäre hier
keine spinne wir haben hier nur
ein springbrunnen
hier geht es nicht lang
hier geht es nicht lange und
hier geht's auch nicht lange
ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwas ist bei
dem springbrunnen ich baue das mal ab ob
hier irgendwie 17 geheim blick wenn man
irgendwie runter geht ich glaube auch
nicht
leute
jetzt auch nicht so
schnell wieder raus wir gehen müssen
wäre tatsächlich jetzt einen anderen weg
ich glaube wir müssen tatsächlich bei
dieser spinne lang ich weiß nicht ob das
irgendwie wie geplant war von dem ding
aber
ich hab' ich hoffe im kreis sich die oat
ich glaube wir müssen da lang
ich glaube wir müssen unser angst ins
auge blicken hier vorne geht es noch
runter
bzw
doch auch nicht erich verlauf mich hier
die ganze zeit ich dachte es wird ein
entspanntes video wir sind ja schon
relativ weit unten ich dachte so einen
auf geil
ihr war das nach
ihr war das
hier geht's lang ich laufe einfach
ich hoffe einfach wie lange ist sich
hier neben hier waren wir auch schon
hier sind wir schon lange gelaufen sind
fackeln auf jeden fall
okay du hast dein herz hier waren wir
auch noch nicht hier können wir erstmal
langlaufen vielleicht ist ja hier nicht
[Musik]
so lange her ist es wirklich alles gut
wir haben die bibliothek leute wir haben
eine bibliothek
ich hab richtig schiss bevor ich in
diese beiden seiten hier reingehen hier
vorne kann auch irgendwie durchkomme ich
habe richtig angst vor dieser dummen
spinne
allerdings haben die bibliothek noch
immer kisten wir sind nur bücher drin
und papiere da schmeiße ich mal weg
und jetzt suchen wir uns mal den kleinen
weg hier nach oben es gibt ja immer so
leitern perfekt hier ist er vielleicht
hat mir dann oben sogar noch eine kiste
wo wir dann gucken können ob wir hier
vielleicht noch mal
irgendwas drin haben in die richtung
diamant hier sind nur verzauberte bücher
effizienz drei schärfe drei glück des
meeres nehme ich auf jeden fall mit und
flamme das hier lasse ich auch hier ich
brauche es auch einfach mal die kiste ab
so dass wir die bücher und papiere die
restlichen teile auch mitnehmen können
und ich werde auch hier vorne mal ein
paar bücherregale ab sondern die
benötigen wir für unser hobby thaus
[Musik]
idiotisch the times ein blender was geht
ja nicht
ja gut dann nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
so viele bücher mit wir irgendwie geht
und lasse noch ein paar sachen hier ich
muss derzeit
hey ich es ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin
dieses video rein gegangen und dachte
mir jetzt wird geil das wird bestimmt
nur ein paar minuten dauern bis sich in
diamanten finde ich bin hier unten im
strom heute mein letztes mal habe ich
auch einige diamanten gefunden relativ
weit unten war allerdings ist das jetzt
natürlich eine andere situation
ich bin
wirklich wirklich gespannt wie lange das
dauern wird wir sind bei minute 11
gerade bei mir
mein plan war es eigentlich das video
unter 15 minuten zu halten ist kommen
allerdings gerade sofort ob das nicht
möglich wäre
es tut mir leid dass ich die ganze zeit
so quatsch wenn ich hier gerade meinem
tod ins auge geblickt hätte aber spinnen
und dann auch noch mit so vielen beinen
das ist mein absoluter tod du kannst
mich jagen mit spinnen so ganz kleine
schneider im alltag wenn die unter einem
sind also irgendwie auf dem boden oder
so alles easy browse setzt also viele
spinnen hin wie du also ist auch nicht
ultra viel aber setzt er ruhig zwei
spinnen hin dann ist alles cool aber
wenn spinnen über mir sind genauso wie
fische oder irgendwas tiere die über mir
sind
mag ich gar nicht ich weiß mir noch
diese drei bruchstein hier weg und dann
nehme ich jetzt mal so viele bücher noch
mit bissig 64 stück habe im dritten
shrek dann sollte das auch reichen für
die anzahl an büchern die ich benötige
die hier vorne noch zack zack und zeigt
dann sollte das jetzt eigentlich
ausreichend perfekt wir verlassen jetzt
diese bibliothek ich weiß allerdings
nicht in welche richtung nach vorne ging
es lang war hier noch irgendwie einen
weg sehr geil wenn dass sie irgendwie in
der höhle münden würde oder so dass man
dann halt gucken könnte ich weiß nicht
ob es oben irgendwo raus ging das man
dann halt gucken könnte ob man irgendwo
lava hat oder so in die richtung hier
geht es allerdings auch nirgends raus
das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt wirklich
einen anderen weg suchen ich glaube
jetzt einfach mal wirklich den weg lang
der vorgegeben war also beispielsweise
hierdurch die holztür ich habe noch eine
kiste
keine diamanten
allerdings eine neue hose für mich und
die gönne ich mir auch mal direkt so
dass die volle ist keine diamanten geht
es hier noch irgendwo lang hier geht's
auch nicht lange wir sind wir sind nicht
so glücklich heute bzw generell an
diesem projekt was diamanten angeht so
wie noch in staffel eins minecraft mit
luca hier gibt's auch nicht lang doch
hier geht's lang
allerdings sind wir wieder wir sind
wieder dort wo diese spinne war
[Musik]
ich habe angst es hört sich so dumm an
aber ich habe angst wenn hier gleich
wieder irgendein krabbel beiden lang
läuft dann schwöre ich euch griechen
herzinfarkt
[Musik]
niemand
die zielanhebung auch nicht lang
wir haben noch immer keinen diamanten
das war wirklich bock ich geh jetz auch
einfach mal nach unten ich gehe jetzt
einfach nach hier und nirgendwo wird
diese riesige spinne sein
irgendwo hier wird sie sein ich habe
vorhin schon wieder im harten sound
gehört
die zombies sind wirklich gerade so egal
wenn diese spinne kommen ich muss er
einfach in die augen blicken ich muss
einfach
vorgehen als welchen man
ich muss das einfach machen
die augen von der haben auch geleuchtet
im dunkeln
auf jeden fall raten palaver sounds
gehört hier unten das lawa hier ist rats
tor nehme ich auch mal ganz kurz mit ich
glaube nicht dass ich den aufnehmen kann
genau kann ich nicht allerdings kann ich
dann mal gucken ob ich irgendwo im
inventar noch was wegschmeißen kann so
ein paar unnötige sachen wie
beispielsweise die sieht blog den
brauche ich nicht ich packe ich mal eben
weg dann nämlich den redstone wir
konzentrieren uns mal direkt hier auf
die lava vielleicht haben wir hier
irgendwie diamant nicht habe einen
wassereimer auf jeden fall dabei das
heißt denn hier hinsetzen und einfach
mal hier über kippen es wäre so geil
wenn hier irgendwo diamanten wir essen
muss doch möglich sein
für vorne die blöcke abbauen das ist die
eigentlich gerade der perfekte ort alter
direkt aber hier drüber das ist ja
eigentlich gerade der perfekte ort um
diamanten zu finden allerdings werde ich
derzeit nicht vom glück verfolgt in
diesem projekt klar okay ich will mich
nicht beschweren ich habe in stronghold
gefunden direkt